hi I'm Chris Wilson from grinding Gear
games this is season 2 episode 4 a
filled of the week a video series where
we highlight interesting path of exile
character builds today's episode is
slightly different than normal we aren't
showcasing a build creative bear
community but one that we've put
together ourselves people who are
looking for ideas of what to run at our
upcoming to we grace the event runs from
May tenth to 24th us time and is
designed to raise money for the child's
play charity if you haven't heard of
them they are gaming charity dedicated
to improving the lives of children by
providing toys and games to over 70
hospitals worldwide thanks to the
generosity of some of our industry
partners we've also arranged a variety
of awesome prizes to be given away
randomly to competitors such as nvidia
graphics cards razer mice and keyboards
and of course piles of path of Exile
microtransactions during the event we
will be offering an exclusive
microtransaction the angelic mask with
all of the proceeds going to the child's
play charity once the event ends the
mask won't be available again the race
itself is a hardcore event with the
properties of both the ambush and
invasion challenge leagues we've put
considerable effort into rebalancing
invasion recently so we feel that the
event will be a lot of fun for everyone
characters that Diane the race are still
eligible for prizes if your character
survives the race then you can continue
that character in the invasion League
afterwards while a lot of the fun of
path of Exile is experimenting with
character builds there isn't much time
in a two-week race to try too many
characters many players want to know in
advance how to build their race
character if you look in the class
forums on path of Exile calm you'll find
plenty of powerful builds but while
highlighting our own one here that uses
a recently introduced skill mulch and
strike this video is quite long so we're
going to demonstrate the build at high
levels before explaining how it's
created as you can see molten strike
launches magma projectiles as you hit
the skill deals a combination of fire
and physical damage and has both an
attack and an area of effect component
this means that there are a lot of
options for how to support it you get
molten strike after killing hillock at
the start of the game so it's with you
on your entire journey with this
character the skills shown here it
generally ones that you get as quest
rewards from playing a duelist there's a
little bit of pressure over several of
the rewards where you need to tweak what
you pick based on what you've naturally
found a couple of gems can be traded for
earlier than you would receive them from
quest rewards to speed up leveling we
use the hatred or four
damage and grace for additional
survivability where possible trader cast
enduring cray whenever you can near
monsters it's flat physical damage
resistance stacks very well with this
characters high armor it's important to
cuss the end feeble curse than anything
dangerous especially invasion bosses
until you have a good idea whether you
can handle the damage potential you'll
have notice that there's quite a lot of
focus on survivability being a hardcore
league this is of prime importance this
build is built to be very survivable so
if you follow our advice in a very
careful with how many monsters you
engage you'll hopefully be fine unless
something goes wrong you will reach maps
with this build the builders high life
and life regeneration its primary
mitigation type is armor it achieves
this by using iron reflexes which turns
all of your evasion and armor this means
that gear choices are substantially
simpler because of asian and armor are
mostly interchangeable armor only helps
against physical damage so having maxed
out resistance this is critical
especially in the invasion league it's
important to know that merciless
introduces a minus sixty percent
resistance penalty so you're going to
want to be above cap by the end of cruel
this build also uses the popular cast
when damage taken and during chrome what
we'll call combo physical immunity when
it really matters this race inherits as
properties from invasion and ambush both
of which pose challenges while we have
rebalanced invasion recently the
presence of unpredictable guests
monsters or invasion bosses can mean
that you have to be prepared for damage
types that you aren't expecting the
league's ambush heritage means that
you'll find in charitable strongboxes
while many people view these as a source
of free items in the ambush League they
are more scary in a hardcore league like
this being surrounded by monsters is
rarely a safe situation but there are
several tools available to get you out
of trouble this character currently
places a smoke mind prior to opening a
strongbox and then teleports out of the
way as soon as the monsters appear which
gives you space to assess the situation
and blinds and monsters for safety it's
also important to be aware what monsters
are in the current area before deciding
whether to open a strongbox some areas
kind of exploding squid so being
surrounded by a few packs of those can
be deadly while the rewards from strong
boxes are substantial you don't have to
open each one you may be able to con a
party member into it flasks are a really
important part of a character's build
some players don't put enough emphasis
on rolling good flasks but they're
critical in a hardcore league like this
one pick up all superior flasks that you
find so you can
trade them with vendors for glass blows
bubbles having high quality versions of
your final flasks provides large
benefits for any marginal effort take
the time to roll your life flasks having
the both restore life instantly and also
remove a status ailment will save your
character's life collection craft as
many resistance flasks as you can
they're not only useful for swapping
into against specific invasion bosses
but also for crafting granite flasks
that this build wants at higher levels
you'll easily be able to trade away your
surplus resistance flasks for anything
your build might lack this character
relies entirely on rare items and needs
no specific uniques we aren't
recommending any uniques because it's
hard to allow finding a specific desired
unique in a two-week event you're likely
to find good leveling uniques and you
should adapt the build to take advantage
of these as you go in terms of rares you
should be prioritizing life over capping
your resistances and getting as much
armor and later evasion as you can for a
weapon any fast weapon with decent
damage will do it doesn't have to be a
sword or even a one-headed item if you
find a better alternative early on 200
weapons can provide a big leveling speed
increase if you're careful the character
we're showing here is after it's found a
five-link armor if you only have a fall
n comma then either drop the melee
physical damage support gem or the blood
magic support gem if you're not using
the blood magic gem then you won't be
able to run the grace or you'll also
need to use mana flasks instead of
granite flasks to compensate the five
link armor is a big upgrade but isn't
mandatory in a similar vein there are
many key decisions you have to make as
you level this character by level 9 your
passive skill tree will look like this
you have a passive point available and
haven't yet committed to one handle two
hand weapons feel free to pick either
cluster based on your current best
weapon it's easy to respec it later it's
also no problem to specialize in one
hand passives but to use a two-hand item
for a few levels you'll be doing plenty
of damage as well as molten strike
you'll have been able to pick up some
useful skills at low levels firetrap and
decoy totem are really good quest
rewards for area damage and
survivability respectively it's also
really worthwhile to get a quick silver
flask quest reward from the tidal island
level 17 you've committed to one hand
and have grabbed these life nodes and
the leather and steel notable which
allows you to use a body armor and
shield without movement penalty the
decision is whether to travel to iron
reflexes for survivability or resolute
technique for damage next you now have
the leap some skill available and are
using a
short for its armor congratulations
level 35 you're now eligible to win any
of the physical prizes were awarding in
the event at this point you finished
normal difficulty and adjust setting
cruel on the passive tree you've
traveled to the Marauder area to get
resolute technique accuracy and critical
strikes are now both irrelevant to you
on the way you've grabbed some decent
notable passives in order to use the
skills easily we're running the hatred
or you had to allocate these two mana
passives you can unspecified gems
because of the cruel resistance penalty
is now important to prioritize
resistances and items you're picking
shields your great place to find easy
resistances you should also start your
collection of resistance flasks level 47
you've now allocated iron reflexes which
allows you to use evasion and armor gear
interchangeably you've traveled north to
allocate the berserking notable you now
need to decide between scooping up with
water nodes such as resistances life and
life regeneration or heading up to the
Templar area for area of effect weapon
elemental damage and life your gear and
resistances have continued to improve
especially due to finding or crafting
rare jewel resist rings level 60 you are
now able to inspect the mana passives
that you've been relying on it's also
worth grabbing 30 dexterity if you plan
to use the grace aura there are some
great notable passives in the template
area that are worth allocating such as
Crusader discipline and training and
amplify on the weight of the Templar
area if you find yourself writing into
resistance problems you can allocate
diamond skin at this point in your
character's progress you can return to
the merciless title islands to get the
blood magic gem so that you can run two
auras if you have a reduced manager I'm
available you'll want to run hatred and
grace otherwise you probably want to use
hatred and whatever resistance aura is
most useful to you it's probably good to
save the normal and cruel Co sequest
rewards until this choice needs to be
made the problem with running a 60-40 or
a split as you have zero manners use
other skills like leap slam or smoke
mine unless you obtain blood magic gems
for them too we'd recommend the hatred
and grace come boom as it is the most
offensive and leaves the little money
left over for other skills but it
requires trading for or finding a
reduced managed em at this level you may
not have multi strike yet run the merely
physical damage support gem until
they're able to get multi strike from
merciless coz at this point you've also
taken off your mana flasks and a running
granite flasks your collection of
resistance flasks ism
moving at level 70 to your character
looks like the early maps character we
showed before your recent passive skill
points have been spent over to the right
on these life nodes and on some powerful
nodes early in the marauder tree you
also dropped the dexterity note that you
don't need anymore as worth making
additional insurance charges in the
template and duelist areas to improve
enduring cry after finishing merciless
difficulty and completing all of the
relevant quest rewards you farmed piety
and the archives for experience and the
items required to prepare for maps
you've also used the vendor recipe to
generate enough glass blows bubbles to
max out most of the quality on your
flasks there are several directions as
character can be taken in the future for
increase survivability you can cut up
here and take the four life nodes that
include holy strength elemental
adaptation is within easy reach these
for shield nodes on the left are very
good in terms of damage if you want to
commit to swords you can get these good
duelist passives including wicked blade
and blade master otherwise cut through
attack speed or near these life nodes
and then work towards finesse and these
damage nodes in the range of tree you
should consider these excellent nearby
nodes such as aspect of the Panther
weapon artistry precise interception and
fencing we've posted a brief set of
notes about this build that include
relevant recipes links to the passive
skill tree at different levels a
breakdown of quest rewards and bandit
choices and notes on gear that we used
these notes are linked from the video
description hopefully this build works
as well viewers that is for us while it
certainly could be improved with better
items it's a good starting build for a
race like this and will give you a
decent character to using the evasion
League once the race is over thanks for
watching this video we look for to
seeing you in the event this coming
weekend we're hoping to raise a lot of
money for the child's play charity and
look forward to seeing what other
awesome builds players come up with in
the event